♪ ♪ ♪
- Les Micmacs l'appellent
le bout du monde.
Gaspé, 15 000 habitants, la plus
grande ville de la Gaspésie.
Elle attire de plus en plus
de touristes et son économie
est en pleine expansion, avec
notamment l'agrandissement
de l'usine de pales d'éoliennes,
LM Wind Power.
- C'est le plus beau coucher
de soleil que j'ai vu au Québec,
ça, c'est sûr.
- Élise Bernier est photographe
Globe-trotter. Elle a
parcouru le monde pendant
une dizaine d'années avant
de déposer ses valises à Gaspé.
ELISE BERNIER, photographe
- La pandémie a vraiment aidé
pour ça. C'est ce qui a poussé
ça, en fait, parce que, bon,
d'une part, les voyages étaient
en arrêt, mais d'une autre
aussi, moi, je travaillais pour
une boîte à Montréal qui a dû
fermer ses portes pendant la
pandémie. Et j'ai eu une offre
de venir passer l'été en
Gaspésie. Je suis tombée en
amour, j'ai acheté un terrain.
- Ah
- Oui, oui oui, craiment, coup
de coeur. Moi, je trouvais que
c'était vraiment un milieu qui c
la nature.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Dans le centre-ville,plusieurs
se sont installés et lui donne
un côté plus urbain.
- Allez-vous prendre autre
chose?
- Elsa Houde est une ancienne
menteuse vidéo. Elle a ouvert
sa boulangerie au début de la
deuxième vague, il y a un an
et demi. Un changement de vie
complet, car elle a dû
tout apprendre.
ELSA HOUDE, propriétaire de la boulangerie Oh les pains
- Moi, je suis native de Gaspé.
Puis, je suis partie pour
les études, j'ai travaillé
en télévision. J'ai resté comme
25 ans à Montréal, mais j'étais
toujours un peu "stand-by".
J'avais vraiment envie
de m'impliquer. Et les étoiles
se sont alignées. Il n'y avait
pas de boulangerie à Gaspé.
Je connaissais bien le milieu.
Je pense que l'expérience
de la vie que j'avais me donnait
confiance pour bâtir une
entreprise qui allait plaire.
♪ ♪ ♪
Isabelle Huard est aussi
d'origine gaspésienne. Elle
travaillait à Montréal dans un
café et vivait dans un quartier
branché. Mais elle songeait
depuis quelques temps à se
lancer en affaires et ouvrir son
propre café à Gaspé.
ISABELLE HUARD, coproprio. et
cheffe barista, Paquebot Gaspé
- On pensait venir s'établir
à moyen-long terme avec les
enfants. On pensait pas le faire
aussi tôt, mais c'était dans
les plans. On s'ennuyait
de la famille, on s'ennuyait
de la mer aussi. Puis, on était
un peu tannés du chaos, un peu,
du chaos de la ville.
La COVID a été certainement
un accélérateur.
♪ ♪ ♪
- La pandémie aura eu un certain
effet également parce que
les gens voulaient découvrir
ou retrouver de plus grands
espaces. La Gaspésie est sortie
du lot comme région excentrée,
qui a connu vraiment
une croissance marquée.
♪ ♪ ♪
- À 90 km de là, nous sommes à
Murdochville : trois montagnes,
de la belle poudreuse, des
paysages à couper le souffle.
2000 skieurs viennent maintenant
chaque année d'un peu partout
au Québec, en plus des gens
de la région.
Élise fait le trajet
régulièrement de Gaspé pour
profiter de ce haut lieu de la
randonnée alpine...
- On est à la fin.
- ... et du ski hors piste.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Veux-tu de la sauce à spag?
- Félix Rioux est un photographe
de ski. Il a beaucoup voyagé
lui aussi, mais il rêvait
de vivre un jour à la montagne
avec sa conjointe Roxanne,
et leurs trois enfants.
FÉLIX RIOUX, photographe
- On s'attendait pas à ça.
On était en pleine pandémie
à Montréal, en gros confinement.
Et puis, au mois de mai,
Guillaume Molaison, cofondateur
du Chic-Chac, il m'appelle :
"Ça te tente-tu de déménager
en Gaspésie?"
ROXANNE PAQUETTE,
conjointe de Félix
- Pourquoi pas? Tu sais, ça ne
va pas bien en ce moment. On est
confinés chez nous. Pourquoi pas
essayer quelque chose d'autre?
- C'était quand même un saut
dans l'inconnu. Murdochville
est une ancienne ville minière
qui a bien failli fermer il y a
20 ans, lorsque la mine de
cuivre a cessé ses opérations.
Bien des gens sont partis. Les
maisons ne valaient plus rien.
- Vous allez pouvoir percevoir
toute la chaîne des Chic-Chocs,
au fond là-bas.
- C'est Guilhaume Molaison qui
lui a donné un second souffle
en misant sur le ski
et le tourisme d'aventure.
Son entreprise, le Chic-Chac,
vient d'ailleurs de s'installer
dans l'ancienne église,
transformée en quartier général
avec un bar et une salle
de spectacle.
♪ ♪ ♪
GUILLAUME MOLAISON,
cofondateur, Chic-Chac
- On sent vraiment que
la pandémie, elle a exacerbé
le phénomène de retour en
région. Tellement de nouveaux
arrivés, une belle dynamique.
Puis, le phénomène aussi,
la tendance du ski hors piste.
Tout ça mis ensemble avec
l'annonce du projet de l'église
a fait un boum immobilier.
- Quand on est arrivés, on était
une des premières maisons
qui faisaient des rénovations
majeures. Les gens se
promenaient sur la rue, puis ils
étaient contents de voir ça,
mais ils disaient : "Hé,
investissez pas trop, faites
attention parce que ça a pas...
ça vaut rien, les maisons à
Murdoch." Puis, un an et demi
plus tard, toutes les maisons
ont doublé, triplé.
- Cette maison leur a coûté
seulement 18 000 $.
Elle n'en vaut presque
10 fois plus aujourd'hui.
Peu après, ils ont convaincu
leurs voisins de Montréal
de déménager eux aussi.
Les enfants sont ravis. Tout est
plus faciles. Ils peuvent
aller à l'école à pied.
Mais ici, cette nouvelle
vitalité à ses revers.
Il n'y a pas assez de logements
pour accueillir les nouveaux
arrivants. C'est encore plus
vrai à Gaspé, où il manque
de garderies et de services.
DANIEL CÔTÉ, maire de Gaspé
- En fait, le plus gros défi
qu'on connaît présentement,
c'est le logement. En fait, même
si on a soutenu la construction
de logements, il n'en demeure
pas moins qu'on n'est pas
capable de rattraper cette
croissance démographique là.
- Il manquerait combien
de logements, vous diriez,
pour une ville comme Gaspé?
- On parlait de 300 à 400
nouvelles unités qui seraient
nécessaires pour soutenir
les besoins actuels
et les besoins de croissance
qui sont anticipés.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Ici, on est une terre entre
montagne et mer. Et pour moi,
c'est le meilleur des deux
mondes, mais autant j'adore
être dans l'eau, donc faire
de la plongée, du surf.
Aujourd'hui, il n'y a pas de
vagues, mais quand il n'y a pas
de vagues, qu'est-ce qu'on fait?
C'est qu'en pagaie pour...
pour se garder en forme.
Tout le monde le dit ici :
"Vous allez voir, quand l'hiver
arrive, c'est la meilleure
saison", alors que tout le monde
ici en été. Puis là, j'ai
vraiment vécu l'hiver. Puis,
c'est vrai que c'est un terrain
de jeu qui est exceptionnel.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Ils ont le champ libre, en
fait, pour innover, réaliser
leurs aspirations.
Ils donnent un nouveau dynamisme
à cette terre d'accueil.
- J'étais à moitié installé
à Gaspé quand j'ai commencé
à parler que j'avais envie
de faire ce projet-là. C'est
fou, fou, fou comment les gens,
ils m'ont pas soutenue,
ils m'ont levée. Ils m'ont dit :
"Elsa, oui, il nous faut ça. On
va t'encourager. Va voir un tel,
les subventions à telle place."
J'ai eu tellement de feedback.
Je pense que les gens ici ont
inconsciemment choisi l'entraide
plutôt que la compétition.
- On est à, je sais pas,
sept minutes de la montagne pour
aller faire du snow ou du ski.
Alors, pour ça, bien, c'est
des plus, plus. Alors,
on profite de l'extérieur
juste en sortant de la maison.
On est proche du parc Forillon,
on est proche de la plage.
- Je viens de Puerto Rico,
donc c'est un gros changement...
un peu petit plus. Mais tu sais,
je suis ici à côté de la mer
aussi, donc c'est ça que j'aime
le plus. Je peux juste vivre
la vie comme ça, plus lent,
pas de stress. Juste tranquille.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Les jeunes, quand ils
reviennent ici, c'est parce
que... il y en a de ça qui sont
allés à l'extérieur, mais ils
reviennent dans leur coin de
pays.
- C'est encourageant parce qu'il
y a eu des années que ça
baissait beaucoup, que le monde
s'en allait, mais ça revient.
Ça veut dire qu'on est peut-être
accueillants.
- Jamais je ne m'en irai de la
Gaspésie, de Gaspé, c'est sûr.
- Les résidents Murdoch, les
anciens de la ville, ils sont
très, très contents de voir des
jeunes familles s'installer
parce que ça ramène de
l'énergie. On réinvente notre
vie. On fait quelque chose
d'autre. On prend cette
opportunité-là pour remettre ça
à zéro et voir qu'est ce qu'on
peut bâtir de nouveau ailleurs.
- Le ski, c'est ce qui a apporté
à Murdochville, c'est une raison
à des jeunes de venir s'établir
et de dire qu'on a plus de fun
qu'ailleurs et qu'on est
fiers d'être ici.
- On voit qu'il y ait un bel
engouement, que les gens sont
présents. Je pense que, bien, on
a créé un lieu que les gens
aiment et qui est rassembleur.
- C'est un milieu de vie que
j'adore. Donc, je me vois
vraiment pas partir pour
l'instant. J'ai envie
de m'investir aussi
dans mon milieu.
♪ ♪ ♪
- L'adage africain qui disait
que ça prend un village pour
élever un enfant, mais ici,
j'ai trouvé beaucoup plus
que sur la Rive-Sud.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Une enfance ici,
c'est magique.
♪ ♪